the independent members are for
themselves but this being for self is
really no less immediately their
reflection into the unity then this
unity is the splitting up into
independent shapes the unity is divided
within itself because it is an
absolutely negative or infinite unity
and because it is what subsists the
difference to has independence only in
it this independence of the shape
appears as something determinate for
another for the shape is divided within
itself and the supersession of this
divided 'no succour dingly takes place
through another but this Super Session
is just as much within the shape itself
for it is just that flux that is the
substance of the independent shapes this
substance however is infinite and hence
the shape and it's very subsistence is a
divided 'no Swit self or the
supersession of its being for self
170 is a transitional passage it's a
little bit hard to follow when you first
go to it in part because it's so jargon
rich and you're wondering what do all
these terms mean as we're moving from
one to the other I think it helps a
little bit if we can spatialize it
rather than just trying to read through
the entire passage but you might say
this is one of those passages where the
significance of it is is really outside
of itself it's in what has preceded and
where we're heading to you notice the
next pass the next paragraph after this
is the quite long 171 where there's a
lot of stuff going in on when he
happened in 168 and and 169 and and a
little bit earlier well as we've brought
in this conception of self-consciousness
as involving desire and desire is in
this case for life we've specified a
little bit what life means and we
specified it in terms of the stuff that
we see right here these independent
members gleetard being part of some sort
of larger whole a unity which is
infinite
when annually it doesn't have a
determinate limit and we've talked about
something this being something like like
a a substance but a substance in terms
of a universal fluid medium and we've
used that that term before here the
fluid medium is in fact life life you
might say with a capital L right life is
a category of things and we're trying to
get to actual living things but because
we want to bring back somehow
self-consciousness which seem to be
outside of life and the life that it is
desiring the life for which it has
Bagheera
you know it's being driven towards so
Hegel let's actually look at the
terminology very closely here it says
the independent members remember the
independent members of the the unity
that we try now that all this stuff
about
see rotation and time you know there's a
whole that these independent members are
members of remember they had to be
independent so that there could in fact
be an out hit on a super session of
transcending a uniting of them into
something they don't have any
independent status by themselves and
they're just vanishing moments as Hegel
accessing so the independent members are
for themselves what does that mean he
says this being for self is really no
less immediately their reflection into
the unity so they are for themselves but
they're for themselves not as sort of
you know a whole bunch of relations with
each other an imminent relation but
rather they're bound into something that
that exceeds them that that gives them
their their location their are their
meaning this unity and here Hegel talks
in these terms that when we translate
them you know seem very very big scale
you know absolutely negative infinite
well infinity here for thinking in terms
of life doesn't need to be the infinite
you know capital T capital I it just
means something that does not have
determinate limits that it remains
within if you think about what life
actually consists in it doesn't mean
that at every moment every single living
thing is somehow beyond all limits you
know that it's the infinite per se but
rather than you know whatever limits are
placed the living thing is already
exceeding that and so you can't draw a
priori limits within which the living
thing is going to say except in an
artificial way right you put something
in a cage now we've limited it so he's
going to talk about this unity you
notice I've drawn like this line down
here to the substance of shapes now why
did I do that
well this unity he says is divided
within itself so we're trying to
represent division here right and you
know if it's an infinite unity
it's also going to be divided not just
into two shapes I know that when we've
got this you know bifurcation into self
and other it often gives a impression
that we're dealing with it's just two
things but really when we're talking
about life we're always talking about an
entire plenitude or a spectrum or a
whole bunch of things thrown in together
so we've got a whole bunch of uses three
different terms that you know are
important here difference division and
determination so you know we've got a
division within the unity because
remember everything Elian unity is
always you know is the unity it's not
pure unity it's always kind of dividing
us within itself also different that's
important to you know Inter sheet and
then determination the stim types you
know the case of beating this thing
rather than being a whole bunch of other
things and as we're moving out from the
unity to the independent shapes or
Gestalt in that it's breaking down into
it now when we see Gestalt in here don't
think of salt as you know alright we've
jumped to a new form of consciousness
you know the term has multiple meanings
in this case it just means something you
know that it is a unity that is a whole
in itself so judy is broken down into a
bunch of other unities he says the the
independence of the shape appears as
something determinate for an other right
the shape which is what this unity is
the splitting up into independent shapes
the unity is divided within itself why
because of the kind of unity us being
absolutely negative being infinite means
it's going to divide itself up and
because it is what's obsess it has the
kind of being there being there for us
being in a presence resisting just you
know analysis or break down into other
things the way the independent members
did right so independence here
independence here or relation of course
between them and then this breaks into
these so he says the independence of the
shape
now we're just considering a single one
of these many different independent
shapes the independence of the shape
appears as something determinate which
means it is for an other determinacy
means that it has to include all
terribly it cannot just be determinate
all by itself disconnected from
everything else a lot of different ways
this could take place we're not trying
to determine the exact form of
determination here right now what does
this mean though the independent shape
is for an other but what it does handle
says is incorporate the other within it
and it also thereby supersedes the other
and is also superseded or superseding
itself through the other so this is a
very important point
he says the supersession is just as much
within the shape itself within the thing
for it is just that flux that that is
the substance of the independent shapes
right so here we come down to this the
substance of the shapes is indeed this
this flux this flu C kite this this you
know being able to move from from thing
to thing which is what this unity is so
the unity of life is breaking down into
independent shapes or rather you know
giving forth independent shapes all of
which are determined by by this so this
is a an important structure
if we distinguished more exactly the
moments contained here we see that we
have as the first moment the subsistence
of the independent shapes or the
suppression of what direction is in
itself that is the shapes have no being
in themselves no enduring existence the
second moment however is the subjection
of that existence to the infinity of the
difference in the first moment there is
the existence shape as being for itself
or being in its determinate Ness
infinite substance it comes forward and
antithesis to the universal substance
disowns as flew in continuity with it
and asserts that it is not dissolved in
this universal element but on the
contrary preserves itself by separating
itself from this it's or inorganic
nature and by consuming it life in the
universal fluid medium as passive
separating out of the shapes becomes
just by so doing a movement of those
shapes or becomes life as praat as a
process the simple universal fluid
medium is the in itself and the
difference of the shapes is the other
but this fluid medium itself becomes the
other through this difference for now it
is for the difference which exists in
and for itself and consequently is the
ceaseless movement by which this passive
medium is consumed life as a living
thing this inversion however is for that
reason again an inverted 'no sin its own
self
what is consumed is the essence the
individuality which maintains itself at
the expense of the universal and which
gives itself the feeling of its unity
with itself just by so doing supersedes
its antithesis to the other by means of
which it exists for itself it's self
given unity with itself is just that
fluidity of the differences or their
general dissolution but conversely the
supersession of individual existence is
equally the production of it for since
the essence of the individual shape the
universal life and what exists for
itself is in itself simple substance
when this substance places the other
within itself it supersedes this its
simplicity or its essence
I that is it divides it and this divided
'no so the difference less fluid medium
is just what establishes individuality
thus the simple substance of life is the
splitting up of itself into shapes and
and at the same time the dissolution of
these existing differences and the
dissolution of the splitting up is just
as much as splitting up in a forming of
members with this the two sides of the
whole movement which before were
distinguished that is the separate the
passive separateness of the shapes in
the general medium of independence and
the process of life collapse into one
another the latter is just as much an
imparting of shape as a super session of
it and the other the imparting of shape
is just as much a super session as an
articulation of shape the fluid element
is itself only the abstraction of
essence or it is actual only a shape and
its articulation of itself is again a
splitting up of what is articulated into
form or a dissolution of it it is the
whole round of this activity that
constitutes life not what was expressed
at the outset the immediate continuity
and compactness of its essence nor the
enduring form the discrete moment
existing for itself nor the pure process
of these nor yet the simple taking
together of these moments life consists
rather in being the self developing
whole which dissolves its development
and in this movement simply preserves
itself
171 is quite a long paragraph and
there's a lot going on there so I'm
going to pause about halfway through
this and do some erasure in part because
what we're going to see about not quite
halfway through the paragraph is this
transition from the two moments that
Hegel has picked out a first moment in a
second moment but he characterizes a
little bit at the beginning but in ways
that are probably rather confusing he's
going to talk about the second moment
but Danny's being a shift of talking in
terms of an inversion of a Karam that's
taking place so let's focus just on
figuring out what the first moment is I
don't think that it's going to be super
helpful to look at the first few
sentences he says if we distinguish more
exactly the moments contained here we
have the first moment we have a second
moment but then what he says about the
first moment you know it doesn't seem to
make that much sense he said that we
have these independent shapes and that
they don't really have any enduring
existence they have no being in
themselves how do we get there that's
that's a strange thing to say after he's
just insisted so much that they do have
enduring existence well what we're going
to see developed in the rest of that
first part of this paragraph is giving
us ultimately towards life as a living
thing so we have a couple different
senses of life being used here
distinguished here you might say being
disentangled from each other and it has
to do with the the what he calls the
existence shape or the you know the
gestalt right we just saw that life
itself is going to split up into a whole
bunch of different Gestalt an
independent shapes how are these then
related to life per se they are they are
living things but what does that mean is
life a sort of universal the way that
that white is a universal for for chalk
and for you know other things as well or
is life a different sort of category
well that's going to turn out to be that
way because life itself is involved in
metaphysics for hate all right so he
says in the first moment there is the
existence shape as being for itself
right being in its determinant as
infinite substance so okay so that's
good we have an existing shape we have
something that has a depth to it we've
seen this developed before we're beyond
even force in the understanding dealing
with the inwardness of things dealing
with the infrared weirdness of living
things organisms now what does that do
he says it you know what we'd expect is
a reference to the universal substance
or as he's calling it life in the
universal fluid medium life as such we
just went through this whole you know
discussion about how life is this ever
changing and adapting and you know
incorporating moment to moment to
moments all of its you know all of its
portions or States or things like that
into through a hole now we want to think
about the category of life per se you
know being living what's the relation of
the existence shape the individual thing
the individual organism to life to life
in the universal fluid mean it's a life
as all living things haven't well this
is where it gets really interesting so
what it means for Hegel to be a living
being an existent shape of life is that
you separate yourself out from the rest
of life from life as a universal even
more interesting he's going to call this
the the inorganic substance the
inorganic that is going to be consumed
by the individual shape he says it comes
forward in an 10
assists to the universal substance to be
living is to stand out in a way
different than other things that do
stand out that resists other things
being there do it involves an activity
of being in opposition being opposed to
the rest of life so any sense m'as you
know it's not dissolved by this
universal element when it's dissolved by
it something else is consuming it right
it'll happen
consciously that every living thing of
course in our bodies are gonna break
down and get eaten up by bacteria and
molds and bugs and who knows what else
but so long as we are a living thing
we are standing out from we are
separating ourselves we're in antithesis
to the universal substance of what you
know we in pushing ourselves away from
it separating itself from this it's or
inorganic nature he says we consume it
life in the thing consumes life it's
it's medium light it takes advantage you
might say of life to be to do something
to exert itself you could say well it
derives all of its energy or something
like that from life per se
sure but once it's got a hold of it it's
going to you know set us off the side
and engage in a process of consuming why
because it's being driven by desire and
desire it just at the level of life is
desire to consume desire to consume what
is real what has being and to turn it
into non being to make it part of
oneself there's an internal
contradiction you might say to the
process of desires workings so he says
here we go
life in the universal fluid meaning
medium of passive separating out of the
shapes becomes just by so doing a
movement to those shapes right this
process of separating this
of consuming it is indeed life as
process which is different than life in
the universal fluid medium these are
different sides of life he goes on me
says the simple universal fluid medium
is the in itself it's it's not you know
really doing anything it's it's what is
being explored right being explored
though by you know eating it up by
chasing it by by exerting oneself within
it by finding out what life really means
which is what organisms do in the course
of their process so it becomes the inner
self and the difference of the shapes it
is the other two that right so all of
these different shapes over here is the
other two that but the fluid medium
itself becomes the other through this
difference why because the center of
attention or the the weight shifts to
the individual thing so he says for now
it is for the difference which exists in
and for itself difference existing in
and for itself is actually going to be
he says the ceaseless movement by which
this passive medium is consumed what
does that mean we're talking about life
as a living thing we've become more
concrete in our analysis now well no
longer talking this is still important
this general idea of life as you know
this booming buzzing confusion all the
stuff out there but now we want to focus
in on the living thing now as we turn to
this inversion which is the second
moment that was being referenced at the
beginning of this this paragraph what we
find is that there's a whole bunch of
things going on that are going to lead
us to a culmination point one that's
that's quite important before we get
there it's worth dwelling a little bit
or reminiscing you might say a little
bit about what he's talking about here
when he says that this inversion is
indeed an inverted Ness into itself
remember back to when we
talked about the inverted world just
enforcing the understanding this is
we're going through some of these
previous shapes of consciousness and
their dialectics can be quite helpful
the inverted world wasn't just
everything topsy-turvy rather inversion
had to be a more complex process in
which inversion involved inverted nough
Swit itself I'm doing all these hand
gestures I hope that they can somehow
conveyed you know a little bit what's
going on just as much as the chalkboard
can it's very difficult to graphically
represent these but what it means is
that inversion is not something so
straightforward as just reversing
polarity rather there's there's the this
other nough scope of what is being
examined so he talks here about the
inversion having to do with a consuming
of the essence and I've got you know
there's an awful lot on this board let
me make very clear that what we're
talking about here are two primary
wholes right the universal or the
universality the essence and the
individual living thing the individual
living thing as we've seen places itself
in antithesis to the universal and it
consumes it
what is it consuming it's not just a
universal like you know thing a hood or
whiteness its life living this you might
say or being being alive so these are
the two important terms here and we're
going to see how these terms are
connected so he says what is consumed as
the essence the individuality which
maintains itself at the expense of the
universal this process of consuming at
the same time as being opposed to being
in an antithesis being a gig and onto
right being being pushing off of this
whole thing is at the expense of the
universal so you might say the
individual is able to draw upon the the
unit
so life small-l is able to draw on the
you know not the capital but let's say
it will call it the reserve the endless
infinite reserve of life per se and so
what's going on after that he says by
doing this it gives itself the feeling
of unity with itself that's worth
thinking about so when we're involved in
the activity of living which is at the
expense whether we're consuming another
life or not isn't the expense of life
per se you might say we're carving out
our own piece of life that gives us the
feeling of being alive that feeling of
being alive is a feeling of unity with
itself you know here would be a classic
example you're in shape so you know
those of us who are out of shape this
definitely apply to us for me this is
just a distant memory but you're in
shape and you go out running and you
feel the wind on your body and you feel
the capacity that you have to go faster
to go further if you want to that is
involving not only a feeling of capacity
but a feeling of unity it's something
that we can come to desire to have this
this this relation of desire to life
itself when we're engaging in other
bodily activity when we're when we're
preparing food or now sitting down and
eating the food when it's good food it
gives us a sense of wholeness you know
when we're engaged in sexual activity
not all of it turns out like that right
but there's the possibility of that
sense of of feeling the unity of one's
own living body really being in one's
body so that's part of what he's talking
about here that's done at the expense of
this this category of life so he says
just by doing just by by doing by so
doing it supersedes its antithesis to
the other by means of what should exist
for itself so
overcomes it engages in an elf hailing a
incorporation of that antithesis that
doesn't mean that the antithesis goes
away but it's transforming in the
process
now he'll says you know sort of
paraphrasing here by the way
supersession doesn't just happen in
terms of the individual at the expense
of the universality there is also a
Super Session going on of the individual
that the individual may not be aware of
so he says conversely the super session
of individual existence is equally the
production of it now isn't that a
fascinating thing to say the super
session on the part of life as something
other to the living thing something
greater than it's something and folding
at something providing it with the world
we might say possibility of relations
either there at the same time a
production of it how so well it's a
production of that individual which is
existing at the expense of the universal
right but it's also a production of all
sorts of other individual shapes or
living things one is not the only living
thing I mean that's almost an
inconceivable thought it's very
certainly a melancholic cut the thing
about being possibly the only living
thing that sort of solipsism may not in
fact be be possible could be the only
conscious thing or the only self
conscious thing but the only living
thing probably not so he goes on and he
says here we go since the essence of the
individual shape universal life right
and what exists for itself is is itself
simple substance when in substance
places the other within itself it
supersedes this its simplicity when life
over here is being life that is not just
being sort of an abstract quality or
category that means it has to self other
which means it has to turn itself into
all these other life's all these other
living beings these these existing
individual
shapes that then take out a life of
their own you might say so he says it
divides it this divided Nisour the
difference less fluid medium is what
establishes individuality that's why
these are individual dividing into all
these living things makes life be what
it is so he says the simple substance of
life is the splitting up of itself into
shapes and at the same time the
dissolution of these differences and the
dissolution of the splitting up is just
as much as splitting up and forming of
members so in these it's not as his life
just splits up into a whole bunch of
shapes sort of like cookie cutter you
know making a whole bunch of little
living things that was in each one of
these there's an entire cosmos of self
other you know all these relations that
we're seeing here every one of these
things is also doing this so he goes on
and he says now we see the two sides of
the whole movement that were being
distinguished actually collapse into
each other they are in fact this is
where you know think about what happened
with the inverted world right
it is the inverted world a separate
world that's over there you know bizarro
land opposed to the world that we live
in
no it collapses into the world in which
we live in because inverted nests is a
characteristic you know this inward
inverted nests of the world in which we
live in same thing with these two sides
they collapse into each other as well so
he says the paths of separateness of the
shapes and the process of life collapse
into each other the ladder that is the
process of life is just as much an
imparting of shape as a Super Session of
it the other the imparting of shape is
just as much a Super Session as an
articulation of shape what does that
mean as sheeps are being derived they
are being derived from life right which
doesn't actually exist on its own we're
finding out that's an abstraction but at
the same time it's what is binding all
of this stuff together so he goes on the
fluid element is only the abstraction of
essence it is actual only as shape
as the other models the other living
things or as a living thing that I know
myself to be or whatever is knows itself
to be through the very processes of you
know capitalizing on its relationship to
life Big L and consuming its consuming
it motivated by desire so he says this
whole round of activity constitutes life
now that was expressed at the outset the
the immediate continuity and compactness
of its essence we were leaving that
behind nor the enduring form we that was
important but that's not what life that
itself is the discrete moment existing
for itself nor the pure process of these
that's important but that's not it
either nor yet the simple taking
together these moments life rather
consistency says in being this whole
thing this is all life a self developing
whole right which dissolves its
development and in this movement simply
preserves itself so now we can think of
life really in in three different ways
in this chapter or in this nut chapters
this this paragraph we have the
individual living thing we have the
universal or the essence of life which
is being drawn upon which differentiates
itself into individual things and then
we have all of this together as life as
such a whole
you